each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hello this is rajesh ballad faculty from
school of information system singapore
management university i'm going to give
the first in a series of lectures on
mobile and pervasive technology and
applications what we are going to do
today's you're going to try and
demystify some of the definitions that
surround this field and we're going to
talk in general about what's the
opportunities in this field ok so this
is actually the overview of what we're
going to cover today we're going to do a
bit of the definitions then we are going
to dig a little deeper and what's
actually most important is what you're
going to take away from the module
hopefully at the end of it you'll have a
better understanding of what these
technological terms mean and what you
can actually do in the space to make a
difference so let's jump straight in
with some definitions now this field in
particular has a lot of definitions and
they can be quite confusing to people
who are not trained in this field so
hopefully by what I'm trying to do is
trying to demystify many of these
definitions now first and foremost we
have the term general computing now this
is a big word that lots of people use to
just mean anything and everything to do
it computers if you have a computer and
you does something it is general
computing after that people talk about
secure computing which is almost
anything to do with making your computer
secure in your password authentication
cryptography all those other things fall
under this space then come to the more
interesting things the ones that we are
going to talk about mobile computing now
mobile computing generally refers to
anything you do on the move now it
doesn't have to involve cell phones the
humans could be on the move and that is
still mobile computing know you could
place a displays in the environment have
humans move from display display that is
still mobile computing but by and large
today mobile computing means that you
have a cell phone and you're doing stuff
on it while on the move then we have
pervasive computing now pervasive
computing is the superset of almost
everything else we have seen on this
slide including mobile computing secure
computing in general computing pervasive
computing just means computing that is
everywhere
that interacts with you in your daily
life so for example if you have a
display terminal that you interact with
that is pervasive computing if you have
a laptop that you use that is pervasive
computing if you use Wi-Fi that is
pervasive computing it is things that
come into your life on a daily basis and
the final destination we have with
ubiquitous computing now these two terms
pervasive and ubiquitous computing can
be confusing to people but don't worry
they are exactly the same thing they are
they mean the same thing just with two
different names if you look up the
definition as ubiquitous in a dictionary
it will say pervasive and vice versa
okay so you big dress and pervasive
computing computing that you can use
anywhere and this is actually what we
are aiming for no computing that becomes
part of your life that is no different
from say breathing or waking up or going
to bed now some other definitions that
you may have heard of and I'm not going
to cover most of them as you can read
the slide and you'll see that I've given
answers to many of these definitions at
least short blurbs the more interesting
months I would say our wireless
computing which is basically anything
that doesn't have a wire which means
that you have freedom of movement then
you have wearable computing which is
anything that you can put on your body
and carry around you also have
client-server computing or thin client
computing where basically you have a
server or something in the cloud and
you're getting service from it this is
actually a very powerful paradigm that
is actually allowing mobile phones to do
very powerful services by using the
capabilities existing in the cloud
things like what project Hawaii is
providing or other services we also have
other more exotic terms like sentient
computing where we use our context-aware
computing where you use the sensors to
understand what is going on and then
provide cool context-aware services to
people an example of this is google maps
or bing maps where your location
automatically is found and then the map
automatically zooms in to where you are
without you having to type anything
that's an example of context or location
aware computing we also have ambien
impalpable computing which is computing
that is basically in the background or
foreground what you're doing and finally
we have
things like disappearing computing which
is actually one of the key things that
people want from computers disappearing
computing is computing that exists
without you even being aware of it there
are a few classical examples of this in
the world today examples being the
cellular network and Wi-Fi networks it
just works you have no idea how it works
or where the base stations are it just
works you have you need no effort at all
to even use it it just works this is
actually what many people are striving
for with computing systems systems that
just work without you needing to
understand anything now let's take a
step back and take up a little walk
through history of computing this is
what computing looks like in the early
80s it was actually driven by what by
these kind of systems known as large
mainframes these were gigantic machines
that cost millions of dollars and they
hosted in one central location and all
the people wanted use it seen on the far
right had to log in using a very simple
terminal device connected using a
network or usually located where the
main frame itself was sitting and then
he had access to the mainframe and
everything was running on these machines
there was no computation being done on
those devices of the people using their
mostly displaced now this was how it was
done back in the 80s in the early 90s of
the late 1980s with the introduction of
personal computers like the PC XD from
IBM and the Apple two from apple people
started having their own personal
computers and then nobody want to use a
mainframe anymore because one of the
problem mainframes is you had to share
with other people if you need to run
something you might have to wait days or
even weeks because there are people in
front of you but your own computer it
was just yours you could do whatever you
wanted whenever you want to do it and
this was great but there's one thing
missing and as you see that was the big
revolution that happened in the middle
of the 1990s that exists until today
there was a huge technological leap
forward there was made possible by
something called the internet all of a
sudden these computers were connected to
each other and that made the world much
closer than it actually is because now
people in China could talk to p
in India to talk to people in Singapore
talk to people in the US the world
became much smaller every computer was
now much more powerful than it used to
be simply because it had access to
resources from around the world and the
Internet is fundamentally the game
changer that has caused the internet
that has caused the computing revolution
that we see today now what about the
future what about looking say five ten
years down the road where do we think
computing is going to go well the future
is mobile mobile and pervasive we
already seen happening and it's going to
happen in much more powerful ways moving
forward basically you're going to have a
one or two devices most likely your cell
phone or maybe a tablet or something
like that that's going to control all
your devices around you and it's going
to pull all kinds of services from
clouds from nearby computer from other
people around the world now these could
involve things like group chat video
streaming push-to-talk gaming enough
optical character recognition speech
translation language translation and
everything is going to be cloud-based
cloud-based and social and that is where
the world is going to go to it is
already happening it's just a matter of
time now given this what is a
fundamental problem with making this
happen well we take a step back and we
look at what a very visionary person
called Mark Weiser who actually coined
the term ubiquitous computing described
back in the early 1990s you should take
some time to read this quote and you see
that what he actually said is that using
computers is really frustrating because
most systems make you do what the
computer wants to do you can do what you
want to do whereas as humans we are
already able to process huge amounts of
information like when we walk through
the woods but we find that really
enjoyable rest everybody struggles to
use a new piece of software so how do we
get over the fact that computers are
really hard to use whereas more
complicated tasks that we do daily
actually easy to do so how can we make
the computing tasks as easy to do as the
really complicated things we already do
daily like playing soccer or going for a
walk or driving a car we find those easy
and fun to do yet we do not find using a
computer fun to youth in many cases well
that come
down to the requirements for making
ubiquitous of pervasive computing work
it turns out that there's actually three
there's three components that need to be
in place before these things can become
a reality the three parts are first you
need cheap low-power computers with
really good displays that are good
enough for people to get stuff done and
with enough inputs like keyboards or
touch screens or something that we can
actually interact with it next we need
network connectivity because as the
Internet is sure nobody really wants to
be disconnected anymore you want to be
able to talk to your friends you want to
be able to pull cloud services you want
to be able to see what's going on in the
other side of the world and finally we
need software that makes it all possible
now let's look at each of these three
things in turn and see where we are
first cheap low power computers we
actually have lots of examples of these
devices already for example on the
bottom right hand side we see a portable
chess player on running on a small phone
we have watches that run Linux or
Windows or other high-powered operating
systems we have cell phones that are
really powerful devices today's cell
phone is more powerful than some of the
computers that were used 20 years ago
possibly even some of the mainframes it
is amazing where the technology has come
in just 20 years then we have all sorts
of specialized sensor devices and
finally we even have leisure devices
that are actually really powerful
computers things like Sony's I bore
which was a personal robot for children
so in terms of devices we have devices
that have screens that have input
modalities things like the iPhone things
like and the latest Android phones
things like the latest four in seventh
ones we have those now do we have the
network turns out we do now in this side
we show the traditional wired
connectivity that ranges from things in
the past like ATM all the way up to 10
gige and optical networks which are
showing up these days but unfort nobody
wants to really plug in a cable anymore
so what about the wireless space turns
out the wireless space we have an
abundance of protocols and network
connectivity we have all the wireless
standards which include Bluetooth
infrared and the numerous Wi-Fi
standards we have
many cellular standards like evdo wimax
LTE 4G all these things are coming up so
in terms of connectivity we are there as
well and in terms of and not just
cellular connectivity also a sensor
connectivity things like RFID NFC and
these are showing up in many situations
now especially in transportation where
many companies i should use NFC Oh RFID
to issue tickets now what about software
unfortunately this is where we hit a
brick wall we don't actually have the
software we have some cases or software
but nothing that really ties everything
together into a coherent story I mean we
have good examples like iOS Android
phone 7 that do a good attempt but
they're nowhere good enough for what we
want to do in our general life the phone
still makes us scream at times and we
don't want that but some of you might be
saying you know that's this law we keep
hearing about called Moore's law that
basically says all problems go away if
you wait long enough so what about that
well I have a graph that I creator that
goes up to two thousand six on the
bottom right hand corner that shows the
technological improvements for five
things critical to cell phones the top
for the top three lines showed that this
cpu and available ram and they follow
what is known as exponential improvement
which means everything doubles about
every 12 to 18 months the fault line
here shows wireless technology and that
seems to double about every two years
the last line at the bottom shows
battery power unfortunately this is not
doubling this has a slow linear increase
so even in the near future battery will
always be a fundamental problem and this
is never going to go away so because of
that we have limitations for what we can
do on the phone which is another reason
why cloud services are becoming so
popular but there is one big glaring
exception and this is the fundamental
reason why creating pervasive and your
bigness computing applications it's so
hard there is one resource that has been
constant for all of time you can go from
the Ice Age to today and this thing is
still the same insight you might have
gone lower any guesses well this is
human attention
ability of humans to process and
understand large amounts of information
it has remained constant from the dawn
of time or whenever humans started
walking this earth and this is
particularly bad because in today's
world we are getting far more
information than our parents used to and
especially our grandparents we are being
asked to process so many different input
streams for example your parents might
have only read one newspaper is not
uncommon for us to be reading 10 or 20
today daily how do you handle all the
information we just can't do it because
our processing capability has not kept
up the huge amounts of information are
now available at our fingertips and this
is why there is a big problem with the
systems that are out there now what can
we do about it well let's look at some
things you might want to agree or
disagree about how do I challengers have
all been solved you know it's all about
software to a large extent this is true
but not completely there are still a lot
of hardware challenges related to
battery and display and inputs but by
and large most of the problems that
people face with your cell phones today
are not related to hardware it is due to
software right and this is a great
opportunity for you because software is
doesn't require specialized
manufacturing plants or specialized
knowledge software requires an idea it
requires a vision and if you have it you
can go build it which leads to the next
problem software is easy the problems
the hardware unfortunately this it's not
through it all the software is not easy
making something that even your
grandmother could use it's really really
hard and unfortunately now that phones
are being used by everyone anything you
build really does have to be used by an
age group from eight to eighty it is no
longer true that you can just target
undergraduates or professionals you
really do have to target the entire
population another perception is that
pervasive computing is just a fad it
will go away this is not true at all
pervasive computing is here to stay
anything is going to become far more
powerful you will see in a few years
your homes will start being connected to
other homes your TT account it's not
uncommon for TVs already to have chips
in them that talk to back-end servers we
all now have personal video
recorders in many places that are able
to customize your preferences and all
these things will just become work will
just increasingly become more common
pervasive computing is definitely here
to stay there will be even more devices
in environment we need a way to figure
it out and finally one common myth is
that all the cool ideas have been done
already this is absolutely wrong there
are many cool ideas out there they just
need to be done this is a great
opportunity what I've covered so far
shows that you know pervasive computing
is here to stay but unfortunately the
main limitation is a lack of software
that actually helps people do
interesting things in ways they want to
do it fortunately this is also a great
opportunity for all the entrepreneurs
out there if you can think of a great
idea that you know solves a problem that
you and your friends have it's quite
likely this will also solve a problem
that other people have we should really
think about doing something and
releasing it and getting a user base and
don't believe that your idea just
because it's simple doesn't mean it
isn't cool the best ideas are always
simple because simple ideas make a big
difference and with that I'd like to end
this first part of the lecture nows see
you later for the next in the series of
lectures thank you